You asked us not to run update frequencies on the true right. Why is that?
Well, because since the company was purchased
They're not what do you know do programs back of the day when Mike owed the company
He would solicit different practitioners like us to hey, do you have any new programs that we could add to our
You know our list of all the programs that we have that
That we're you found to be helpful that you created you found to be helpful with your patients and such and then you know
You know probably once a quarter there'd be one or two programs that were added and so we always suggested people to hit
There was a button that you can update frequencies on the true right and your program would be updated and it would not disturb
any
Self-created program, so it would disturb the program I created for you
Well, those days are gone, you know, there's not new programs being made and
There's no sense updating frequencies and we've had people hit update frequencies and it messed up our program and we had to
Fix it, so just don't do that anymore
And you don't do that with the Attila Robin there isn't even an update frequencies option with the Attila Robin
And if you somehow found it don't do that because all those programs
The Attila Robin are my programs. I wrote them so there's I don't have a website where you could update frequencies at this point
So if there's anything to update I will send you a flash drive so